[Music]
on my knees
Oh
[Music]
I don't recognize this well we don't
have to recognize it we just have to
save it shall we
in order for us to be able to relate to
this movie we need to have things that
we are all familiar with and who's not
familiar with Mercedes right so I think
it was a good choice I was very
impressed the car Diana drives is very
elegant and not too flashy very chic and
practical
[Applause]
[Music]
we get to keep the car and left driving
yay what are your superpowers again I'm
rich
[Music]
[Applause]
Bruce Wayne has no shortage of ways to
get around these up is pretty cool
civilian Mercedes car that we're showing
in the movie which is pretty awesome
[Music]
Zack Snyder the director of the film saw
the vision GT which was an electronic
remote-controlled concept car that was
designed by Mercedes for the video game
Gran Turismo and because it was just
designed for the game it was never a
real functioning vehicle and because Ben
Affleck who plays Bruce Wayne and Batman
is 6:4 in order to make it work for our
needs so they expanded the car about 10%
when they built it out this is really a
dream project for any designer to be
able to do something like this because
we were responsible for the original
concept that has now been translated
into this movie car so the original show
car didn't have an interior so we had to
basically create the natural physical
interior
[Music]
this has got to be one of if not the
coolest Bruce Wayne related vehicles I
mean it's not even a wheel you can't
even call they're reinventing you all
right like it let's film it let me shoot
rockets right to put Bruce Wayne behind
the wheel of an experimental prototype
vehicle like the VGT it's a great fit I
think they made it also just to
specially to look awesome a lot of
people want to take pictures of the car
[Music]
and almost supportiveness a this huge
support from the Saudis both widths or
background cars and this project on the
whole and having Bruce Wayne's car I've
never seen a car like this associated
with any character of any movie so it is
really unique and super exciting
[Music]
you
hey everybody we got new Justice League
coming tomorrow and it sounds like
everybody's getting a brand-new car I
love the way they pitched that like
Wonder Woman gets her own Mercedes
Batman gets his own special concept car
like when you're making a movie as big
as Justice League Mercedes will
hallucinate you a car then build it like
they had an idea for a car that was in a
video game that they then literally
built into a car and had to make even
bigger so that Ben Affleck who's huge in
real life could fit into it there's some
new giveaway stuff happening at the end
of the video but be sure to subscribe to
get everything this weekend it's New
York Comic Con so there's other Batman
related stuff happening but mostly
Justice League tomorrow and there's some
special stuff tonight that's happening
that I'll talk about in a second the
interesting thing about all this is that
we haven't really seen a whole lot of
this version of Bruce Wayne outside of
the Batcave in Batman V Superman and
that's only after he's been Batman for
about 20 years and he's almost at the
end of his career like he hasn't been
Batman for a little while
when Man of Steel picks up and then they
have that big opening set piece during
Batman V Superman where all that
Kryptonian stuff triggers him and you
get to the events of that movie and
suddenly he's Batman again and
Superman's sacrifice inspires him so
he's got this big second win but he
still has most of these assets like you
see Wayne Manor that's in ruin so it's a
little hard to place him or Wayne
Enterprises because at various times in
the comics he's super rich I like he
jokes about it in the trailer what's
your superpower I'm rich so he has a
giant fleet of cars the one that he
drives that any given time is just
suited for whatever story they're
telling like if it's Batman the Animated
Series they tend to drive older classic
looking cars because that was sort of
the style of that series which actually
had my favorite Batmobile of all time
Batman the Animated Series is still the
coolest looking Batmobile in my mind
because it has this futuristic yet very
classic look to it because that was the
whole idea to blend these modern design
concepts with this really classic
Sensibility
I know everybody's wondering about that
final trailer that they're dropping are
they gonna put Superman in it and I know
there's still questions about who alfred
is looking at here i just love some of
the conspiracy theories like some people
think that it's Supergirl some people
think that it's Green Lantern because
they get called out in the movie no
lanterns no Kryptonians but because of
the
purfles stories about how they recut the
ending of the film and how they change
things I'm just assuming that they
actually took a lot of the extra stuff
out so they're keeping it a little bit
simpler like they're not trying to over
stuff it with characters so while I do
think that they'll tee up the idea of
Green Lantern's
in the DC EU the chances that we'll see
a physical Green Lantern show up are
relatively small that doesn't mean that
we won't see it it just means that I'm
not expecting it but I think the whole
clue about this Alfred scene is in the
way they put music in that trailer
it's the Man of Steel soundtrack like
when junkie XL was still scoring the
soundtrack when they released the
initial trailers it had some generic
junkie XL music / the trailer took I
believe that an enemy is coming from far
away I'm looking for warriors this
stranger but then as they've sort of
hyped up how hopeful the movie is like
it's all about the return of hope to the
world the return of Superman they put
Hans Zimmer's Man of Steel soundtrack on
it so I think that's just the clue as to
who shows up
you didn't just save people
to see the best parts of themselves
older
I have recognized this way
we all have to recognize
[Music]
so what'll happen is I'll post my
trailer video tomorrow morning and
because they haven't put Justice League
tickets on sale yet I'm actually gonna
do a giveaway for IMAX gift certificates
and they'll just be generic and you can
use them for Justice League so if you
watch my flash videos flash is starting
next week the giveaway for the first
couple weeks until we get to Justice
League will be for movie tickets usually
I do flash rings but just because
Justice League is so big I figure people
would rather do that than the flash
rings just because it feels a little
more relevant but if you didn't know
flash is back next week so all you have
to do to enter that is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video I'll
announce a winner when I post my Justice
League trailer tomorrow but also if you
didn't know today is Rick and Morty's
Szechuan sauce state they're actually
selling Szechuan sauce in select
McDonald's maybe there's one in your
area I'll actually put the website link
in the video so I got new rick and morty
coming and it's sort of like new footage
day I guess marble saw that the Justice
League trailer was coming out they're
not releasing infinity war but they did
drop new Thor footage so I'll post a
video for that next to why you wait for
everything you can click here to get a
look at the new flash costume and you
can click here for more Rick and Morty
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight